quick question should men be more
vulnerable
check this out why are weak men such a
problem
well weak people are a problem in
general and I don't mean physically weak
I mean cowardly let's say and deceitful
because I'm thinking it more in terms of
moral weakness well there's a variety of
reasons is first of all if you can't
support your own weight let's say
then someone else has to do it and
that's not good and then if you don't
make your pathway if you don't pick a
forthright and useful and Noble pathway
through life then you'll become bitter
showing weakness can be a strength too
not weakness
vulnerability that's that's a whole
different thing to admit to to admit to
the fact that you're vulnerable that's a
form of courage that's not a form of
weakness but that leads you to take
whatever steps are necessary to deal
with that properly it isn't some facade
that you're invulnerable no one is
invulnerable by any stretch of the
imagination
should you be vulnerable the answer is
yes and no when it comes to God your
mission you should be extremely
vulnerable and in fact I think the
biggest reason why so many men suffer is
because they are too rigid in this right
number one they act as if there is no
such thing as higher power Mission God
which which is fine if you believe that
but if you don't believe that there is a
higher power then you don't believe in
Mission because you don't create your
mission and maybe this is just my
opinion but mission is given to you
right is revealed to you right well also
think about this if you don't believe in
God then who's the ultimate law Giver
because we're all just humans right so
why should another human being tell you
what to do what is right and what is
wrong because you're right maybe someone
else is wrong they're wrong might be
your right
even a government why should you listen
to a government of all the laws because
they're just humans right
check this out whatever whatever God
means to you the universe you know
Consciousness your subconscious doesn't
matter you need to be extremely
vulnerable because you need to own up to
your mistakes you need to know where you
up you need help you were just a
man you cannot do that by yourself so in
that realm absolutely be vulnerable I
think a lot of people just use swearing
as a crutch word because I don't believe
that they can speak good enough and
people will listen to them if they don't
use swear words they need to try and
Elevate themselves and sound cooler I
think
it's weak I also think it's vulgar and
it is a sin apart from that I believe it
absolutely is important when we look at
God because you see who God is to you
what you believe in determines your life
look at islamist extremists who kill
Christians and even their wives because
of their beliefs
so in this context I'm going to say no
you do not want to be vulnerable to your
girlfriend but you want to be open this
is very important there's a difference
right be open be able to vent express
some of the the worries right of of you
know maybe I'm going through this right
now be completely honest but I'm gonna
get it done because I trust God and
we're going to move forwards now I
believe that a lot of people just argue
misunderstand each other because
they think of words differently and
their meaning is different for different
people and they just talk right past
each other before I tell you what I
think about this let's look at a few
more opinions one thing that I feel like
men have not been given the permission
to do and to be is a very important word
which is called vulnerable
when I work with a lot of men I coach
single men or I coach men who are
struggling in their relationships and I
start talking to them about
vulnerability well have you said that to
her and typically guys responses back to
me will go
she doesn't want to hear that or
she's going to think I'm a weak man if I
tell her that like I can't tell her that
and really that's just not true you see
the fact that you can show up and be
vulnerable with your woman or with a
woman that you're getting to know
actually shows a tremendous amount of
strength we all have some work to do
because you can say all you want there's
so many women I know that I want a man
to be as vulnerable as he can be cool
stories a lot of y'all say that and then
when it happens you find yourselves
grossed out and you don't acknowledge
the fact that you've engaged that
behavior well you've psychologically
told that man that what he did was wrong
so of course in his future relationship
she's not going to do it listen I've
done that whole thing I've done that soy
boy will open my heart up right off the
top let her know the things and she
wasn't okay with it part of it was my
fault but also her reaction was crazy
and look I learned from it no it doesn't
mean that now I never open up I do but I
wait until I'm ready you said soy boy
yeah is that the notion that the
solution to all your problems as a man
is to simply be more vulnerable is false
it's just false now is there Merit in
you expressing where you're struggling
as a man to people in your life that
deeply care about you that part I think
is absolutely necessary and I've seen
that in my own life with the men in my
own life where they bring their
struggles and their challenges whether
it's you know a health issue that
they're battling with you know going
through cancer trying to lose 60 pounds
you know and cut weight trying to eat
healthier and stop binging uh you know
trying to quit porn struggles in their
marriages struggles in their finances
sharing those parts of themselves when
they're really struggling has a deep
amount of value because then we can
contribute to each other's lives if
you're unattractive if you can't be
vulnerable
like men to be vulnerable if they're
attractive or Rich vulnerability is week
and men aren't supposed to show emotion
and I see why men think this because
women are not always receptive to
vulnerability or a man showing emotion
but I think that's often when it's done
the wrong way when you guys don't know
how to do it in a way that's authentic
or show emotion in a way that's not you
know just asking for attention I think a
lot of you guys don't know exactly how
to go about this or you're doing it the
wrong way and in those cases it's not
attractive to women because it's not
being used properly number one you want
to reveal enough about yourself to where
this person can see that you have depth
and character to who you are and you're
not just surface level but you don't
want to just spill everything and reveal
everything you want to leave a little to
be desired right you want to leave a
little room for imagination because
there's no reason for me to care about
you this is another one of the lies that
the world has told us that we supposed
to care about everybody
I don't care about everybody you don't
need to care about everybody you really
don't and when you say let them in you
know what I think that it's better that
you don't let a whole bunch of people in
it's better that you don't let a whole
bunch of people in letting people in is
what women do that's why they have an
opening in their body they let you in
that's a that's another effeminate uh
trick that the world has tried to bestow
upon men we're supposed to let people in
no you let people in that you want to
let in I have I'm convinced
that when a time is right you find that
woman and you want to make it your wife
that you have no problem letting her in
right you're gonna melt
because you did all the vetting you
decided it was right or not and she's
the one
and then you're gonna be right then who
else do you need like these are the
things that historically speaking did
Define manhood and now they no longer
Define manhood I think that you can show
up the moment of deterioration for the
moment James Bond started crying it's
like you know you take even that take
even bonded emasculating that's like he
has to be in touch with his feelings why
why can't he just shoot people and drink
martinis and seduce women and what's
wrong with that right but that is again
a cultural move and you're right against
masculinity in pretty much every sphere
and the conflation of masculinity which
is good with toxic masculine that all
masculinity is bad and so we need to
feminize Society overall we don't need
to feminize Society overall any more
than we need to masculinize society
overall what we need is for men to be
men and women to be women that doesn't
mean that women are barefoot and
pregnant in the kitchen as I've said
many times my wife is a doctor right
what it does mean is that there are
essential qualities to being a woman
that are different from many of the
essential qualities to being a man
all right so my views of what a man is
supposed to be like how he should talk
how we should think how we should treat
people all of it is based on the Bible
Jesus is the perfect example he was
strong when he needed to be he was
humble and he was vulnerable when he
needed to be and throughout his lifetime
he was perfect he was the perfect man
the best example that we have of a man
and first let me just comment on this
I do not agree with people who are
selfish and who do not care about other
people Jesus said in Mark 12 30 you
shall love your neighbor as yourself
just think about this if everybody lived
this way
we would live in a whole new different
almost perfect world
people would stop to help you if your
car broke down
they will not throw signs and swear at
you in traffic if you made an accidental
mistake while you lost your focus a bit
because your child just died
instead of judging a lady who looks lazy
by seeing how tall the grass is growing
in her yard they would come in to ask if
they could help and in doing so they
might realize she's in a wheelchair and
they hear how her husband is in the
hospital and could not mow the lawn
even just small things like this
understanding another person standing in
their shoes first before acting would
change the world these are small things
and when we look
on a bigger scale people will not just
murder ripe steal or bribe or play
political games using taxpayers hard
earned money for their own sick
world domination plans
now let me just explain this and don't
misunderstand what I'm saying here
just being selfish and caring about your
own family is actually part of the
problem and it makes the world the world
worse
let me explain
is because a lot of people just care
about their own family so they would do
crime or bribe or just drive past people
who are in need of help you know and the
world becomes unfriendlier it becomes
more hostile it becomes more violent and
there's more crimes because people are
just selfish they just care about
themselves
this is the reason the world is in this
state
but if you are a real Christian
then you would actually care about other
people and not just your own family
love your neighbor as yourself
if you did that the world will be
different and if you call yourself a
Christian you don't do that then what
are you doing because you're the same as
the rest of mankind exactly the same as
the sinful world are you not supposed to
be the light
and Acts 20 verse 35 says
in all things I have shown you that by
working hard in this way we must help
the weak and remember the words of the
Lord Jesus how he himself said it is
more blessed to give than to receive
this makes me
vulnerable in the sense where you can
see what I'm feeling and thinking
without looking weak
and in this way you can be vulnerable
and you should be standing up for what
you believe in
now for those of you who say that
everyone should just look at their own
family well what about those who do not
have families anymore
what about the lady whose husband died
in a war whose son died in a war so that
you can live safely in your own country
so let me say this clearly if you are
selfish and you don't care about other
people
then you are evil
and you live in darkness
now as a man
being vulnerable about the right things
at the right time
is not only good it is necessary
just like I was now vulnerable with you
guys about how I feel about people who
are selfish you should show people what
you believe in and do so in boldness
that is the right kind of vulnerability
Zechariah 8 16. these are the things
that you shall do speak the truth to one
another render in your gauge judgments
that are true and make for peace in
Ephesians 4 25 says therefore having put
away falsehood Let each one of you speak
the truth with his neighbor for we are
members one of another
I do not agree with men who lie you know
when you ask them how they feel about a
certain issue or when they are trying to
deceive you with lies now you need to
speak the truth in boldness and if it's
a private matter then just say it's
private I'm not going to share with you
um I rather not it's private but don't
lie about it and then my advice is if it
comes to personal issues don't just
trust anyone with it don't just speak to
anyone you meet at this happen or hey
this happened oh there's back at home or
my wife did this or all my son don't
share everything only with people that
you can trust and very importantly when
the time is right
Proverbs 3 verse 5 trust in the Lord
with all your heart and do not lean on
your own understanding you can trust God
with everything in you but you cannot
always trust people people you need to
be very careful in who you trust but you
can't trust God because he knows what's
going on in your life anyway he knows
everything so you need to be vulnerable
to him especially
but you don't need to be vulnerable to
all people
especially in age today where
a lot of people want men to be more like
women and they said I'll be vulnerable
be vulnerable be more vulnerable be more
emotional be more like this
you don't have to not to people that you
do not trust
now should you be vulnerable at times
and even cry and be emotional
you know
a lot of the old Generations
not so many I didn't grow up that way
but a lot of people did
fathers telling their sons be strong a
man don't cry these kind of things you
know I didn't grow up that way my dad
did teach me to be a strong man
but also that I could open up when it
was the time and with the right people
you're not a robot you were not created
to be a robot you were created to feel
something
it just depends on how you do it with
who and with what at what time well let
me just say this first it is wrong to be
weak in a sense of having no values and
morals and vulnerable in the sense of
always complaining about everything and
crying about everything and just being
clingy all the time
feeling like you cannot stand on your
own feet that is weakness
this is wrong
and weak men
like this make the world a worse place
it makes Society weak
because you're sitting back
you're complaining about everything and
you want other people to fix your
problems
no
a lot of men today they need to get a
backbone and take responsibility for
their own actions for their own life
1 Corinthians 16 verse 13 Be watchful
stand firm in the faith act like men
be strong
didn't say be weak but other people do
things for you and just roll over it
says be strong it takes courage to own
your mistakes
to own it as a man
to make it right to say sorry to the
people you wronged and to move forward
in life stronger than before that's what
mistakes do they are not there to make
you weaker they are there to make you
stronger because you can learn from your
mistakes and it makes you appreciate
life more the things that you have the
things that you're working hard for
makes you appreciate it and you start to
see other people differently as well
and you start to get more love for the
world I mean the good things in the
world for the things that you're working
for for other people for your family
let's go back to this verse again read
it with me Be watchful stand firm in the
faith act like men be strong
and now it says let all that you do be
done in love
but hear me out
there will be tough times that's what
this world is you will encounter
difficult times struggles and then it is
okay to cry to be emotional even if
you're just alone in the shower or in
your room closing the door
I went through a few things I cried when
my brothers died I cried when my dad
died I cried many times in my life
and that is not weakness why do you
think God gave you the ability to cry in
the first place let's take a look at the
Bible there are strong Fierce Warriors
who cried let's look at David
there were weak men who didn't want to
take on Goliath because he was a giant
you know
but David when Fearless
and after that there was many battles
many and there were many warriors within
Fierce Warriors
and they cried
1 Samuel 30 verse 3 by the time David
and his men came to the town it had been
burned down and their wives Sons and
Daughters had been taken captive
then David and his men cried loudly
until they didn't have the strength to
cry anymore
you need to understand that these men
with David they were Fierce Warriors you
know the movie 300 those guys don't even
stand a chance against these guys
for example 2 Samuel 23 verse 8 says
these are the names of the Mighty Men
whom David had Joseph bashabeth and
sakamonite he was chief of the three he
wielded his spear against 800 whom he
killed at one time
go ahead and read the rest in your own
time describes all the other amazing
Warriors there and what they did look I
am vulnerable about the right things at
the right time and it is important for
me to be vulnerable especially with the
people that I trust for example with my
wife also on this channel and the other
one I'm also vulnerable about my life
things that were very hard for me
because I'm sharing that with you guys
knowing that it can help you as well
because there are many of you who are
going through things that are
a lot worse than the things that I went
through and then just sharing with you
what I experienced how I handled it and
how it came out stronger at the other
side
can maybe also help some of you
for example I share with you the death
of my two brothers
how close I was especially with my
second brother
I mean
I shared out my videos for a reason and
that's not just from I mean especially
at the star it wasn't always just easy
talking about it but I knew I had to do
it
because my life is short
and the rest of my life here on Earth I
want to use it to help other people I
want to use it to help you guys and to
do that I need to be vulnerable about
the things that are extremely important
for those of you who missed some of the
videos where I was vulnerable
here's a few examples for you
and I could see my sister standing there
near the hospital room and she just
looked at me and ran and hugged and I
knew man it really is brain dead he
really is not here probably anymore and
then my family just said hey
Daniel we just kept the machines alive
uh the machines on him so his body is
still alive but he's brain dead so we
just kept him alive for you to say
goodbye and uh I walked in and I asked
could I have some privacy with him so I
draw the curtain slows and I sat down
there and I looked at him and his body
at that time he was working out a lot
you know it looked really good
and um
I remember looking at it and touching
his hand and talking to him and just
saying things like hey
if you can just wake up you know I was I
was a little bit in denial
of course he didn't wake up
I talked to him a little bit and then
[Music]
sorry it's a little bit hard
and then I started to talk to God
because
you know I knew he existed and I started
to ask him this question why did he take
my first brother why did he take my
second brother now why do we have to
grow up so poor why did all of these
things have to happen there's a lot of
things that I talked to him that I'm not
going to share in this video but I I
started to ask all these questions and I
started to get more angry
and uh we had this conversation I can't
even remember how long it was but I just
remember there was this one moment where
it just stopped and his ass if I could
hear God talk to me it's not like a
physical voice but it deep in my heart
and my my soul my spirit
Daniel
you ask all these questions but what are
you doing with your life
and he's like I can see my own life from
his perspective this brother the second
brother who died he he had
he was probably the best I was
oh
[Music]
the way he lived his life and uh the way
he talked to people
here's the good one he was the good one
and now he's gone and uh I was not the
person who I became and going out
drinking
so much becoming rude becoming arrogant
becoming a kind of
let me tell you my story
I pray to God for a long time about what
I have to do in this life when I became
a Christian after I lost my second
brother
I didn't know what I wanted to do with
my life I didn't know what God wanted me
to do so I started to pray and pray and
I kept on praying and he was quiet
I started to study psychology
and then I finished psychology and I
still did not have peace in my spirit
about psychology I kept on praying
I just knew I wanted to help people
and then one day I was traveling between
China and Hong Kong I was at the Hong
Kong part and my train I just got out
and I turned right and I walked and the
other train opposite of us just stopped
and the doors opened up and all of these
people just came out and I just stood
there and these people just coming past
me just I've never seen so many people
in my life and I looked at them and I
felt God speak in my spirit and asking
me Daniel where do you think these
people are gonna go when they die
and in that moment I felt God's love for
them and I looked at them
and I started to pray and I said God
you know where they're gonna go
I don't want them to go to hell I want
them to go to heaven I want them to have
eternal life
if you want me to preach the gospel to
people of different cultures then I will
do it but you need to tell me I stood
there I couldn't move the tears just
came down my face that night I went home
I picked up my Bible and I read and I
said
God I'm going to continue reading I'm
going to continue growing with you
spiritually
as I've been doing for the last few
years but God I want you to speak to me
about what you want me to do in this
world you speak to me a little bit about
something here something there something
here but this big thing that I've been
praying for so long
you need to answer me
and I'm not going to leave you until you
answer me
and I continue to read where I stopped
the previous night and I opened and it
was Romans
Romans 1 verse 1.
which says Paul a bond servant of Christ
called as an apostle which is a special
messenger personal chosen representative
set apart for the gospel of God the good
news of salvation
when I read this part I felt how God
spoke to me again with a remower deep in
my spirit it stood up and I knew God was
speaking to me
and he was calling me
to spread the gospel
to all cultures and all people and the
world just changed
it was not the same
I've I found my father
he was still alive back then
I phoned him I said Dad
I explained to him the whole story this
is just what happened and he was quiet
on the phone
I said hello you still there
and after a while he started to speak
and he said sorry I'm crying because God
told me a few years ago while you were
still young
that he has called you to preach the
gospel and to take over from me
so I cried but I had this peace
ah the purpose that surpasses all
understanding knowing what I have to do
with my life
you see my dad he said I didn't want to
tell you because I wanted God to tell
you
and it was at the right time because I
wasn't ready if he called me to be a
preacher before then I wasn't ready
you know
my dad it was the best example of a true
Christian that I ever had
and then
when he got cancer
he had multiple myeloma cancer so he had
a lot of pain we couldn't even touch him
at times
and uh you know
it just brought him closer to God
because he walked the path with God day
by day I could see how his faith grew
and you know that did something in me
changed something in me it showed me
what I was still lacking it was not only
example for me but for everyone
and what I lacked was to fully surrender
to God no matter what Matthew 16 verse
then Jesus told his disciples if anyone
would come after me let him deny himself
and take up his cross and follow me
you know God was already starting to
work this in me to fully surrender
I was afraid
that God would take my dad away after
the two brothers I lost and all the
other people
I was afraid
but then something very unexpected
happened
God
gave me this message Luke 9 58.
and Jesus said to him foxes have holes
and birds of the air have nests but the
son of man has nowhere to lay his head
to another he said
follow me
but he said Lord
let me first go and bury my father
and Jesus said to him
leave the dead to bury their own dead
but as for you go and proclaim the
kingdom of God
you know I felt this truth hate me
straight in the heart
because I knew
I was not ready yet to share the gospel
because I did not yet fully surrender to
God this was after I started Theology
and before I started the YouTube channel
and man God was speaking to me and then
as I watched my father
how he handled
that pain that God allowed in his life
shook something within me and I decided
there and then I'm gonna follow Jesus
just like my dad
whatever happens
I'm gonna put him first
above everything else
because only then
can I truly share the gospel until the
day that I die until my last breath
so should you be more vulnerable well
yes and no it depends on the context
if you use it in the right way at the
right time with the right people then it
can be good and you should do it because
it is necessary to stand up for what you
believe in and to tell people what you
really think what you believe especially
if you know that it can help them as
well
let me leave you with this how can you
continue to live with yourself if you do
not stand up for what you believe in
you can't
now if you want to hear my testimony
more about who I really am how I grew up
and watch these videos here and I'll see
you there in these videos I'm going to
be extremely vulnerable
before you go always remember life is
short so don't waste yours Church guys